boy things with your mom got pretty
intense down there huh
all like east coast west coast you feel
me
act like a parent talk like a peer i
call it parenting
i learned it from my own dad who used to
walk into my room and say what's up
sweathog
honey i would love to let you go to the
concert are you kidding me i think
concerts are rad
hello i was a hall raiser a what i
followed hall of notes around the
country
one summer rich girl just spoke to me
i was dating this girl not not dating i
guess i was following her too
kind of mom just doesn't trust me and
it's not fair
she trusts you it's just the weird stuff
happens at concerts
boys get urges ew dad
is there something you want yes there is
to connect with this girl right here now
come on pretend i'm not your dad we're
just a couple of friends kicking it in a
juice bar
what's a juice bar okay a mulch shop
whatever dad
no who's dad who's dad i'm i'm marcus
from biology hey haley how's it going
with you and dylan
has he tried anything inappropriate with
you
girl
hey what are you doing i don't know
nothing just talking to some dork i met
in a malt shop
phil's ossa fee a hardbound collection
of all the life lessons i've learned
such as
always look people in the eye even if
they're blind
just say i'm looking you in the eye
or if you get pulled over for speeding
tell the policeman your spouse has
diarrhea
philosophy i said we are over
why don't you go out for a nice bike
ride dylan again huh
some guys just do not know how to play
it
dad what are you doing oh right just uh
test driving my new soup strainer i dug
it out of the halloween stuff see what
people think
do people want their real estate advice
from someone who leads
or from someone who follows i'm betting
these babies are coming back in a big
way
buy low sell high people are gonna see
this and say
that guy's high
hey sorry to bother you sir we're doing
work next door nick the main so we're
gonna have to shut down your water oh
okay no problem yeah it shouldn't be too
long if you happen to need it there's a
porta potty out front
thanks yeah hey nice mustache
yeah man you too brother
you too brother
you three get better acquainted will do
fine
will do i cannot believe you got a dog
without consulting me this was a major
family decision
it was wrong yeah yeah i'm sorry um but
we have talked about getting a dog for
years
and you're the only one who wasn't into
it because i knew that i would be the
one taking care of it
that's not true oh no we will all help
this is a great chance to teach the kids
responsibility that is exactly what you
said about luke's paper route
you don't get to be two-time
non-consecutive district salesman of the
year without thinking inside the box
that's right i said inside you know why
because while everyone's chasing each
other around
outside the box you know what the box is
empty which brings us back to our formal
dining room
now any questions can we have our candy
now
just as soon as we go over what you're
going to tell your parents and what was
our style
pre-war craftsmen good good
how many square feet 3 500.
phil dunphy yo
it's like that you just you just stare
down on them let the eyes do the work
your mouth might be saying hey we cool
but your eyes are like no we not
nice to meet you no it's not
it's all good snows
yo yo
okay i've seen you guys you two
two keep it real no means son
not really please stop that's cool
oh god that's my back sweetheart ow oh
i slipped in the baby oil oh where are
you from originally
i could defeat you if it came to a
physical confrontation
oh no no i don't know about this should
i call a doctor no
no no no you're very strong homes
thanks okay nice nice soft landing there
you go
oh okay i am on my side though so just
flip me right back and we're good
we'll be good i just need to get flipped
right on my
back and we should be fine so hi
can i talk to you for a second claire
likes to say
you can be part of the problem or part
of the solution
well i happen to believe that you can be
both
listen claire feels terrible
why don't you talk to her why i know
what she thinks
a cold digger you know she's saying gold
yes finn
well i i know she said that but that was
a long time ago before
does they buy me nice things yes of
course all beautiful things
look at this yellow red blue
all the colors do you think i can't live
without this
take them away phil gloria
we all know you'd be fine without
underwear i mean
we know it's not about that no it's
about me not being accepted by my new
family
that is not true gloria look you're a
beautiful woman
in fact you're probably one of those
beautiful women who doesn't even know it
no i know it so it's natural for claire
to wonder about you and her dad
this family's very protective of each
other i remember the first time claire
brought me home
do you think jay thought i was good
enough for his little girl no way
but over time he realized that i loved
claire as much as he
did and by then mitch had brought cam
home so i was golden
claire just needs a little time then
trust me she'll be the most loyal friend
you've ever had
honey haley and i have to go fill out
some paperwork why don't you
throw the linens on the bed oh and move
the car before they tell us
okay oh my god what is that shirt pretty
sweet huh haley dunphy moving company
see because we're moving you here
and here and also
here man you used to love it when we
swung you like that
i bet we could still do it yeah yeah oh
no no no no no no don't you dare pick me
up and take that shirt off what why
it's cute it's not cute do you see
what's happening out there people are
walking around and judging each other
no they're not oh really you didn't see
the way muffin top across the hall was
looking at me people can be cruel
so take it off fine
oh my god put on a shirt i don't know
what you want from me
you only get one chance at a first
impression i suggest julia child
because it's easy to do save the giblets
think fast oh wow buddy
i'm sorry i told you i got to change the
light bulbs and then help your mom with
those signatures
never mind because it was a stupid idea
anyways
i've always said that if my son thinks
of me as one of his idiot friends and
i've succeeded as a dad
if he wants to go the wrong way on the
escalator i'm on board if he wants to go
into a restaurant and pretend we're
australian think good day mate
toss a few shrimp on the baby for me and
my joey
yeah right nicole kidman minute work
here we go take 12. hey buddy i'm home
hey dad think fast oh
wow now my arm's starting to hurt a
little really cause my face
feels great come on dad let's not turn
on each other
we could be here a while yeah okay
you're right
here we go take i you're not even trying
and we have all the answers and we want
to pass all that onto our children
but if you scratch beneath the surface
you don't have to dig very deep to find
the kid you were
which is why it's kind of crazy that now
we're raising kids of our own
this is a milestone we're accepting that
our little angel isn't perfect
that's right and it's okay
i i take it back she is perfect
i guess that's the real circle of life
your parents faked their way through it
you fake your way through it and
hopefully you don't raise a serial
[Music]
killer
you